okay let's move on now to one way that
companies are dealing with global
warming emissions and that is carbon
offsetting firms plan to reach net zero
through planting trees or restoring
carbon sinks like peatlands this is so
the amount of co2 absorbed can balance
out the amount of co2 they emit but is
carbon offsetting a viable long-term
solution tom
what are your thoughts is it a good tool
to help us reduce emissions
it's a very important tool
to have in our toolkit for dealing with
uh climate change but it's only going to
be a useful tool if people believe it's
real the integrity of the offsets in
other words if you're putting a an atom
of carbon into the atmosphere today
you've got to be able to point to
somewhere where you're taking an atom
out of an atom of carbon out of the
atmosphere today you can't somehow
borrow from the future and i think quite
a lot of the schemes seem to be drifting
into sometimes thinking we will we will
put carbon up now and we'll take it out
later and i think that will really uh uh
not sustain public confidence not
sustaining even economic confidence in
offsetting and that will destroy one of
the tools we'll need to play a part not
a dominant part but certainly a part
michaela what are your thoughts does it
work or
our carbon offsets a smoke screen
effectively a way of offsetting guilt
and saying well if we pay we can carry
on doing what we've always done
i think that's absolutely it i think
that i do see that it's a tool in a
toolkit but i don't think it should be
the one that we're focusing on i think
that we know what we need to do is
actually stop producing as many
emissions that should be the priority
not trying to do some sort of creative
accounting to make it look like we're
not causing as much harm because
basically what carbon offsets allow a
lot of big businesses and countries like
the uk to do is continue polluting and
emitting and continue fossil fuel
extraction by saying that you're
balancing it out somewhere else but
actually a lot of these carbon offsets
aren't as reliable as they say they are
if you're doing tree planting if those
trees don't end up growing um to full
maturity if they end up like dying
different ways and that's not actually
gonna offset as much carbon as you're
saying it is but also there's an
important um kind of thing to bring in
here around justice because a lot of
these carbon offsetting um activities
they are kind of like modern day
colonialism it's called carbon
colonialism and how they go into many um
countries all over the world and seize
land from indigenous people and grow
monoculture of trees this is happening
in kenwa in um the sangwei community in
kenya at the moment for uk for the uk
government's offsetting um kind of uh
strategy and it's really important that
we bring awareness to the fact that this
offsetting can actually cause a huge
amount of harm and in many ways it can
also um kind of repeat the same cause
the same harm that has caused this
crisis in the first place and i think
that we need to make sure we're
centering justice and i don't think that
sometimes offsetting can do that
one very brief thought from you tom is
it a long-term solution
uh
well yeah i suspect we're going to go on
needing covering offset but kain is
right to say there are limits to what
the party can play
we have to scale down an investment in
fossil fuels at the same time as we
scaling up investment in the uh
renewables say the net zero alternatives
and and that's a difficult task we've
got to make you can't just switch off
the fossil fuels or we'd all be having
the kind of job problems mckayla's
worried about carbon offsetting casting
costing if we actually use it to destroy
people's
possibility of living so we've got to
make a good match between those two
things and offsetting will play a role
tom and michaela we are running out of
time i'm going to have to interrupt you
thank you very much